[Music]
should the nixon administration be
afraid of you i think you know the
answer to that
mitchell
i've had some disturbing news sir
corporation watergate uh security guard
must be wide open
the next 48 hours is gonna be crucial i
don't know how to put this uh we're
wondering about your wife
y'all gonna just stand around you want
to ask me some questions
you worked for martha mitchell's husband
yeah she's completely insane loud now
she's a truth teller unreliable i love
her
i told you no more interviews it's a
ladies magazine
i will say how i feel and if that gets
me banned off air force one i will fly
commercial so you were banned from air
force one
you're good
you can just keep your mouth shut we'll
be fine
if the american people knew half of what
i do they wouldn't have much to approve
of
the loudmouth [ __ ] wife of israel's
becoming too much of a liability
[Music]
where is everyone okay there's no need
to get hysterical i am calling my
husband
[Music]
there is something terrible going on
he's saying that none of it happened a
lot of women suffer from paranoid
episodes for you
should the nixon administration be
afraid of you i think you know the
answer to that girl martha are there
microphones in here
look let's just take a breath
my mama slaps me harder than that
[Music]
you